lui c'est laid et l'adorent les maths et
les sciences
il pense que beaucoup gagnerait à aimer
les maths et les sciences ou si d'une
part on retrouve de plus en plus dans
nos quotidiens
pour comprendre le monde d'aujourd'hui
me semble indispensable d'aller assez
loin dans notre compréhension des maths
et des sciences
mais ça à la limite ce anecdotique ce
que je veux vraiment faire c'est
partager avec vous ma passion pour les
mathématiques et les sciences
surtout les mathématiques car une fois
que les mathématiques nous ont conquis
on voit plus le monde de la même manière
sur cinq forums je propose de vous
joindre à moi dans l'exploration de
l'univers mathématiques et du monde de
la science aaas le voir il ya trois
types de formats le format principal est
une série d'une vingtaine d'épisodes qui
en ce moment et sur la relativité
générale
si j'ai des idées pour ce qui viendra
après je fais aussi des biographies des
plus grands mathématiciens et
scientifique de l'histoire car ya
souvent des histoires assez improbable à
leur sujet enfin je vais aussi le
commenter certaines actualités
scientifiques en essayant de les mettre
en perspective par rapport à un contexte
mathématiques ou scientifiques plus
large si ça vous paraît cool je vous
invite à vous abonner à partager cette
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux et
j'espère que je vous verrai la prochaine
fois